Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host Rawkode.
This is Clustered part seven part two.
Work that one out. Last night, we had
an episode of Clustered,
and I unfortunately had a power cut which
put an abrupt end to our debugging. So
I'm gonna be joined again today by Noel.
We're gonna dig back into cluster 15
from Tim Hawken and see if we can
work out what went wrong and why we
couldn't work it out yesterday.
As always, please remember to subscribe to the
channel and click the bell. This means you
get notifications for all the awesome content as
well as helping other people discover it. We
have a very active Discord where we're always
talking about cloud native, Kubernetes, and a mix
of other technology related subjects. So come in,
join us, have some fun.
Of course my employer lets me do this
on their time. Thank you very much Equinix
Medal. If you wanna check it out, you
can get $50
coupon
by using Rawkode live. This will get you
around one hundred hours of compute.
Alright. Let's get back in the scene. Hey
Noel. How are you today? Hey.
Good.
Are you ready for some revenge on this
cluster?
Yep.
Okay.
We'll just we're just gonna dive straight into
this I think. So let's get the screen
share up.
I've got the control plane note here.
If you can just join type echo and
then we'll get ourselves
hopefully
fixing a broken cluster.
Well, let me try and recap while you
do that. What kind of happened yesterday? Oh,
you're already in magic. Yep. I'm in.
It's a
after my power cut, I think you decided,
oh, I'm I'm gonna know what was wrong
with this. And you dove back in and
you you uncovered a couple of things. So
do you wanna just explain what happened after
my my power dropped?
Yep. So I went in and started looking
at the locks and it's unlike
the API server was basically restarting kind but
we kind of missed that because we were
just kind of restarting it here.
It was restarting at the trees. The like,
the stack trees was, like, so huge. Like,
I had to scroll down a lot. Then
I kind of dipped the cube APS of
files between the working cluster and this one
and found, like, the limits was, like, two,
though. So what happened basically was the APS
of it was getting throttled. So it never
properly completely started up.
So
I think our well, I think yeah. Our
hypothesis last night was that there was something
ruining communication between entity and API server. The
the problem was it was just never we're
fully starting. And then silly thing to miss,
but
I believe you have removed the dodgy resource
limits and we have a working API server.
Is is that correct? Yes. We should have.
I'll let someone run back and
Yeah. It looks like it's been running for
Yep.
What is that? Thirty minutes?
And I mean, that's interesting but
I would expect it to be up for
like
twelve hours. Yeah.
Bit longer?
Alright. Okay. So
does that mean
let me reset up our aliases.
So we got kubectl,
kubectl. Yeah.
We have an APIs server that works. Okay.
So we yeah.
Did you poke around anything else? Or
I saw those bots are completed, but then
they said, like, you're going to reshare it.
So, like, okay. I stopped there.
I I need to refresh. So kind of
almost all the ports are kind of booked.
All the ports they enter
are completed.
That is just wonderful.
Alright.
What?
Completed?
That's weird, isn't it? Yep. So when you
describe it for what it actually says so
if I just do okay. Let me just
add the completion
too.
I'll just tackle a couple of comments just
now. Rawkode says, oh, the API server was
restarted.
Yeah. I don't know how we missed that.
I mean, we were restarting ourselves.
Like, I even when I watched it back,
I realized I said let's skip the resource
limits and mounts because it didn't know the
API server was restarting. I just assumed it
wasn't an issue. Very naive of me on
this show. I should always check everything.
And will you just ask where where was
the resource limit set? I believe it was
the API server.
Yeah. Yep. It was a manifest.
Nice. Okay. It could be something this is
something interesting.
Oh, shit. Sandbox. Sandbox changed.
It's
I wonder if it's something to do with
the pause board.
Yeah. It's making me think
that either the root secret is
no. Maybe container d has been messed with?
I checked that container d system d service.
It seemed fine.
So
I kind of stopped over the yesterday. So
let's check it again.
Yeah. Cool.
Container d.
It looked fine. I couldn't really find anything
wrong with it.
Or there must be config file for container
d. I don't we should find a mistake
there. Yeah. Well,
yes. So normally, just got to see the
environment file. I I don't see anything.
Let's jump into the
Etsy directory and see if we can if
there's a container d dot yaml toml.
Yeah.
No.
Alright. I think it's fine because it's Yeah.
Yeah. Can do that.
I'm not gonna assume anything is fine ever
again after yesterday.
Yeah. There's no config, it just seems to
run as container d.
Do you mind if I what happens if
I shut down container d? Bad things happen.
Right?
I was gonna run it manually on the
command line just so we could actually see
the log output but I guess the the
more sensible Yeah.
The more sensible approach would be just to
use
journal d.
That seems fine, I think. I
I don't see errors.
Alright. Let me throw an idea through you
then.
So even before we fix the clustered port,
right, if we don't get the networking up,
none of the other ports would come up
right.
That's true. Do you think we should focus
our efforts on maybe the serial namespace first?
Yep. Let's just try the ceiling port and
see if it's the same error. Okay. Cool.
It could
Yeah. I think
why do we have more? Oh, wonderful. Yeah.
Why not?
Alright. We got a question in the so
I'm gonna I'll I'll tackle that. Navin Kumar
is asking
what is a POS container?
That is a great question.
Yep.
The POS container
is the what holds
the
namespaces
and c groups for all the other processes
and the networking as well.
So it's created to bootstrap all of the
c groups namespaces and networking stack and then
the other processes are launched into those namespaces
so that they can work. And I think
as far as as far as I know,
it just literally runs a sleep infinity,
and that's that's all it does. It's just
there to be the parent of
boilerplate,
that substrate for the containers. Is is that
right, Noel? Yeah. So that I yep. That's
what I also believe. Like, it's there just
to set up all those names, pages, and
c groups, then you can just start on
the other port. Like, a port is a
collection of containers. Right? So and since the
con the containers seem to sorry. Share the
same network names, please. It's there to, set
up all those things. Yep.
Because if our main container both hosted it
and it died, then we'd lose every all
the other processes and stuff like that. So
and sleep should never crash, I guess. Maybe
that's why it uses that. I'm not sure.
Okay. So that's all was fine. So I'm
just going to check the locks.
Yes. Go for it.
The fact that it says completely makes me
think that we got an x zero from
it which I think is a little bit
strange.
Oh, we got because this was a oh,
so restarting.
I'm gonna throw something out there like if
we do a
Cilium
get pods. Like, we've got a whole bunch
of stuff here.
I'm kinda curious what happens if we just
delete one of the pods like if it
comes back and completes again or if it
runs like I'm curious
if this is affecting all new pods. Yep.
Let's delete the one that's not running.
Yeah. Let's not delete the one thing that
is working on this cluster at the moment.
That's a great idea. But I guess it's
just keep keep on restarting.
Oh, yeah. I'm hoping it goes running. If
it if it completes again, I'd be a
little confused.
And, like, my first assumption was it is
something with container d was tweaked. Like, is
it some the thing that's, like, c group
or, like, the sand I think the sandbox
is related to the post container. Like, I
could be wrong, but that's what I believe.
Also, the other one is completed. Right? But
it didn't
oh, it didn't get deleted. It's still terminating,
so I'm just gonna try and see.
So We've not got a new one. Oh,
no. We do have a new one. It's
running in it. Okay. Yep.
Okay. Let's wait for a bit.
Nice coffee.
I don't think that's doing anything right.
Yep.
That's
probably if I describe, I think we would
probably get the same thing.
Yeah. Shall we check the event log just
in case
something happened in there?
Yeah. Let's check the events.
Oh, so it got assigned,
but it's, like, waiting on it. So it's
probably the same thing. So the edit could
just do you wanna okay. We've got a
describe. What's the name of the edit container?
I think we have auto complete. We should
be able to log.
Clean Cilium state. Should we try and get
the logs from that?
You'll need to load autocomplete. I don't think
I loaded it.
No. It's there. Oh, it's there. I loaded
it.
Cilium, what is the port name?
It is F 25.
Yep. And it was clean Cilium state.
Yeah.
Let's try to check the previous one.
Tested keys. No. Not here.
There is nothing.
Oh, so it's just the board is not
initializing.
Oh, is it something to do with
the scheduler?
No. The scheduler has applied the label to
it though. Oh, yeah. It has. Okay.
Pod initializing
would tell me that it can't set up
pause container. Do we have cry control?
Pod.
Yeah. We should probably create that file. Right?
So Yeah. Let let's create that config.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's somewhere in this file. One of these
files actually has
the configuration for it. I just saw it
yesterday.
Well, it said no. I don't know if
that's for us or not. But, well, he'd
feel free to drop a little bit extra
details there. What what did I say that
was wrong?
Let's see Kubernetes.
Just tell us to create the container deconfig.
No. Not this one.
Which has do you know the continuity config?
I I have to, like, figure it out.
It's, like, a container
runtime dash pocket, I guess. Yeah. Hold on.
I'll find that. I I just keep using
my lead message from Discord many, many minutes
ago.
Right. This is a file. Right? C r
s I k l dot v m l?
I've got it here. Or c r I
dot v l? That's
it.
Okay.
C r f t l is working. So
we should be
So the Sileum on this node is fine.
So we're gonna need to configure container d
on the node that that other Sileum was
scheduled on and then see what container details
this is running on that. Right?
Yep.
Okay. So,
let's jump over. I mean, it's not running
on any other one. So, let's jump onto
g j.
And I will create a container d config.
What was it? Cry control
dot yaml.
Yep. Weird bug. Right. Okay. Then cry to
that save. Yeah.
Okay.
So there is
Selium.
That's not the new one, though. Can we
just But when I read when we list
the containers, you should see the post container.
I had never
like, when it's, bad, I saw it, like,
with Docker, but I don't know, like, if
it it shows, like there should be post.
There should be a way to show the
container.
Or it's just like, oh, we have the
CTR.
Test.
Maybe
it's not I think we had to put
in the namespace, cates .i0 dash There's also
a c list.
Do we need the namespace?
Does that work?
No. No. I think it's just like the
namespace is case.io.
I think it's what is it? Get, man.
C p r.
Oops.
I don't know. Let's try that.
Okay. Must be for c. Are you
runtime config?
Where is, like, would it pass in the
Well, CTR would list every every container on
the host. I don't think anything is running
on this container d.
Well, it is also suggested we try try
cry control p s, which may or may
not display what we need.
Let's move those comments up there. Yep. So
nothing is running. That's kind of makes sense.
So let's try it.
Get container.
That
seems fine.
Let's try.
Do you wanna should we get the, yeah,
get the logs? Let's see if this container
is completing of the editing.
Why is it not auto completing?
Oh,
did you see that? Failed the same plugin.
Yep. Celeb c n I.
Okay.
I'm gonna stop this so we can try
and maybe process some of this. So
these logs are coming from the container d
runtime or from the containers that it's running?
Like, do we have an op c and
I? Or we do it?
Okay. Yep. We do have it. So it's
probably, like, the c n the c m
port field to start. Right?
But the problem is none of the port
containers are running.
Like, if I do a c r I
c l p s on the other node,
I can see the ports.
And here, there's, like,
nothing.
Why?
Okay. Let me go back to the other
one and get the notes and see if
it's actually ready.
Okay. The notes are ready
and the polls are scheduled.
Okay. So there's an error message in the
container d logs that said failed to reserve
sandbox name.
Okay.
Yeah. What what do say? Like, prep post.
That is actually good.
It's not running. And I suppose
Should we restart the CLT? Trying to do
is
give me a minute. So I was trying
on the other terminal. It's like in the
PCM.
Right? I just want to see if both
which nodes they were scheduled on. So the
one that is running is on
I guess, it's a master
and the control plane, and the other ones
that are, like, not completed must be on
the other nodes.
Yeah. Something is something has to be wrong
with container d. It's unable to start
any
any container whatsoever.
So, like, should we try the other approach?
Like, just run
So there's a warning, not blocking dev mapper.
Let's see.
That's it. Oh, so there is a conflict.
Why is it not killing?
Oops.
Just gonna kill it. Oh,
sledgehammer.
Alright.
I approve. Always must be the system d
one that's starting it up. Yeah. We need
to stop it and then run it manually,
I think.
Okay.
And let's make sure we run it with
debug if possible.
Debug.
We'll do a log level debug.
Yeah. Dash l debug.
Okay.
Dash dash l
level.
Oh,
that was oh, what is this? Failed to
destroy network for sandbox.
Oh, p p c n I bin, and
the folder was present.
Yeah. The folder
was present,
but we didn't have that binary. See if
we can find something that's missing.
Well, there's something interesting on the control plane
node.
Do you see that? So
I thought I'll jump on the control plane
and see if we've got the still m
c n I there. And we do, but
it's also been replaced.
Yep. And that's probably the reason why it's
crashing.
But it's it's working on the control plane.
Right?
No. It's actually the port is kind of
getting, like, restarting. So, like, if you look
at the restarts, right, it was, like, probably,
like, 360 restarts.
Okay. So we divert the binary?
Well, I
yep. Let's yeah. Just save it.
Not that I don't trust you, Tim, but
I am gonna
move
Cilium c and I to Cilium c and
I maybe
broken.
And we'll bring back that old
Oh, yeah. C and I.
And then
we should
how can I restart?
Let
me just force this. I'm gonna kill her
only running
pod. Yep.
Whatever
happened.
Hopefully
that works.
Is it possible for them if the control
plane node does not have as working CNI
that the other nodes are be unable to
start or does that an unrelated issue?
That I'm not sure.
Okay. So Cilium is running.
Let's see if it gets healthy. Could be
yep. It's running. Right?
Yeah. And I wonder if the other one
is stuck in in it because it's waiting
on the control plane node to come online.
Oh, no. We should start system continue on
other machine. Yeah. That's it.
Okay. That still seems happy at least now.
I wonder what that old binary was.
I think it would not be able to
start the other note on the other notes
because the binary was kind of corrupt. So
then, like,
one if it's not, then it won't be
able to, like, set up networking for the
other ones. So I'll I started the con
community,
and I'm gonna start the unit.
It seems hell fair. Yep.
Yep.
Okay.
That must be like
oh, it still had errors.
And let me
yeah. Let's check that.
Why is it still in and it we
should probably delete that one thing,
or is it not not healthy?
Well, do we need to get the binary
in that directory to still in pull that
itself?
See, the unit container is supposed to install
the CNI.
Or is it not?
I don't know.
I know.
At least for Flanagan or anything. Other than
I think the unit container is supposed to
install the CNI.
So I guess it's the same thing for
f.
Oh, let's check if
the so I think the edit container for
Selim
and see what it actually is.
So I'm just gonna pull up a serial
manifest.
It's, like, serial quick start.
Edit containers.
So it's supposed to run the init container
dot asset script.
And the name of it is
okay. It's called clean seal in state, so
that seems fine.
Hold on. So
you went to the edit containers.
It's got an edit container dot s h
and that's this is pulling the binaries?
Yep. Yep. Okay.
So
that being unable to start, it must be
due to the sandbox problem. So we need
to fix this.
Although that's because it can't find the plugin.
Where's the first error? Let's make sure we're
not skipping anything.
In fact, I'm gonna stop container d.
Again?
And just run it manually.
Oops.
So I think so it's first says fail
to destroy. So whatever was there previously, it
was not destroyed.
And then it's probably so let's delete that
port
that is already running, like, which is, like,
stuck in the unit state.
Deleting stuff, I can do.
Alright.
Let's
No. Let's keep the continuity running.
So I'll just keep continuity running.
Force, great, period.
Alright. Those ciliums are being nipped from orbit.
I see the same error.
No.
Oh, we should check if the
let's open up the cilium manifest and see
if the volume mounts are right.
If it doesn't have the host part mode,
it won't be able to, like, find that
part right.
Okay. So edit the Siviom.
Now Yep. That was quite a lot. Let
me jump down.
Let's switch to host path. That's easier.
Okay. We've got FireRunStillium.
Looks
I mean, it's in Okay. We have of
DNI bin.
Yep.
Yep. And where is it referenced? It should
be referenced
in volume modes,
which should and the mode part should be
a host of the n I bin.
Yep. That seems right.
Alright.
So
we might be missing something related to actually
bots and bug grab and probably we'll see
them not coming up.
Magnum was asking, are we allowed to give
tips? The answer is 100%
yes, please.
If you've anything
you've got, send it to us.
So we got sandbox errors,
container d on the worker nodes.
What are we what are we missing?
It feels to me that container d has
something stored, some state stored that we need
to be able to flush somehow.
We could like delete
the wall, log continuous.
Does
that have a cache? No. Does it have
a No. Lib?
Oh, yeah. There's stuff out here.
I'm half tempted to say
maybe.
Yep.
But you should first stop on data d
just to yeah. Oh, it's not running. It's
it's not running. Yeah. We've we've been running
it manually. Okay. Yeah.
Why don't we Yep. We quit. Maybe Why
don't we move it?
Okay. So now there is nothing in there.
Yep. There it just doesn't even exist.
Where are the other
locations?
I think it should create it.
So is there gonna be
no. There shouldn't be anything else. Right? It
yeah. I think if you start again, it
shouldn't just recreate it.
Yeah. So we got a whole bunch ah,
look at that. Cleaned up orphan ID. Yep.
It's cleaned up.
It's like garbage collected.
So yeah. There's loads of stuff that run
container d.
And
oh, it's running now?
No.
Oh, it's the other one.
I mean, we're not getting any sandbox errors.
That's good.
Yep. So let's just start the system d
service like the normal one and I just
restart your bled.
Good call.
Okay. That seems fine.
Oh, it's doing something. It's it's doing stuff.
Yep.
Okay. It's good. Same here.
Darn it.
What if
I I I keep doing this and I
don't think it's ever been right yet. But
what if
Tam pulls a dodgy image?
I'm gonna do my favorite change and change
the pull policy.
Why is that not?
But it may seem right. It's getting it
from
okay. Okay. The local ones.
Docker IO, Selium.
So I don't know why it's pulling from
Docker Hub, like, with new manifest actually pulls
from query, but I guess it's fine.
So roll out what was the command again?
Oh, there was two images. Right?
What was there?
There should be two. Right? One for container
and one for the normal one.
Good call.
Yeah.
And we should be at rollout
or, like, delete the pods.
I mean, I'm gonna what is it? Roll
out, restart, d x Restart.
Okay.
And then let's run a wee get pods
watch on it. Okay.
Terminating,
pending, pending, init, init. Come on.
Yeah.
It's not gonna move on from init, is
it?
Yeah. So the chat people are saying that
you could QDM fix this. Yeah, of course.
Like we could have QDM fix the entire
cluster but
we wanna work out.
I think the mission is not more to
work out what was done to the cluster
and how it was affected rather than fixing
the fixing the bonus. It says it can't
find anyway, like, if you look at the
errors, it says it can't find the plug
in c m c n I and the
control plane has the fly binary.
So should we manually copy it over?
Well
yeah.
We we could manually copy it over and
see if it supposed to be automatically
installed, but
there must be something
we are missing. So we could copy it
over, Mandy.
And if I
let's see sorry. Opt.
See if I can.
Oops.
What just happened?
Oh, let me log in again. I just
logged out logged out. Oh, I know. I
might.
Alright. Let's get that binary. So the CNA
then
hopefully, there's a hopefully, I can just get
in fact, we could just copy the script.
Right?
What was this script? What was this c
n I install? Here we go.
Yep.
I mean, we can just run this on
the host.
But I guess the binary is actually inside
the container, so we actually need to get
the binary outside of that image.
Well, I was hoping there was gonna be
yeah. Actually, there's a better way. So it
register
machine.
So if I do,
I think,
If the if all the image, I should
be able to find the binary.
You wanna find that from the the actual
image cache on the host?
Yep. It's VarLib. Right?
VarLib container.
Yeah.
Right. F dash name.
Oops.
C m dash c n I? Yeah. Was
that it? Yep.
So let's
let's see what we've got here.
It must be in one of the yep.
For tires.
I thought it was pulling the images.
Snapshot.
S yeah. Is there
let me try to see. I see here.
It should list the images. Right? Does it?
Yep.
So
It's not it's not pill damage.
I guess,
is this image kind of correct?
Let's check the
let's run this in the host and see
if the image ID matches Yep.
On the control plan.
Oh, there's a version 3.2,
and here we have, like,
three three point one. Yeah. It has the
right ID.
Oh, wait. So there must be in one
of the manifest,
the post container
that might be specified,
and
in that, it might be specified as three
point o and, like, we're just trying to,
like, pull 3.1. So if you look at
the cube, like, configuration,
so
for that Kubelet. Right?
Okay. Let's actually go there.
Was it updated?
This looks like
Where does it specify? Oops.
What did I do? Let me create it.
I just
where does it specify which POS and HDUs?
That must be some configuration.
I
thought it was in the binary itself.
Can I?
No. It must be in one of the
configuration because, like, in offline environments, like, we'll
have to pre pull this image.
So it must be one of the configuration
I have seen it.
But
let's check if we have actually
access to the Internet.
Okay. That's working.
Can we use CTR to pull the image?
Oh, sorry.
Yep. I think we are in the same
page there. CTR.
I think it's, yep, we can just do
pull
what is it? Kates dot I o slash
g c r. Oh, what is that? Kates.gcr.i0/pause.
Kates
G c r I 0
/ pause and then 3.2.
And I would suggest we just pull the
cilium one too.
185.
Let me just
so we have updated one.
Let me pull the Cilium one over here.
Okay.
So I never seen any error messages.
Oh, wait. Hold on a second.
When we ran container d, it told us
that all the images were there.
Let's check some for some weird configuration.
Maybe it's missing some plug in or, like,
the configuration doesn't
or the doesn't
know it. Like
I think I broke it.
Alright.
If Start start a new session.
Just call that process.
Okay. I'm here. Okay.
So you said let's check out the container
deconfig. I didn't think there was one. Yeah.
And we already blew the starter away.
I don't think there's anywhere. I don't think
there is a container deconfig.
Let's check-in at c. Let's
see.
No. There's nothing in the h c for
continuity.
Just try my this is out.
No.
And
why let's
do that?
Why is it possible to specify? Alright.
I wanna take a look at the container
d logs again. I'm not
I'm not happy with something, but I don't
know what yet.
Yeah. Something with oh, okay. Finally, actually got
full screen. I don't know what happened, but
the teleport thing. Right? Like, it's actually easy
to read.
Mine's just
Container. I just see something must be running.
Okay. So
I
can't read that. Sorry. Stop.
D.
Container d. I don't get it. So it's
something.
Container d dash The filter. Okay. Yep.
I wish it we're running a debug log
in. I'm about to say, I wish it
wasn't so for both, but
I don't think the debug logs are helping.
I could just run it without debug logs.
Yeah. I think you're right. Let's let's just
do container d.
Wow. Oh, it's nice.
Oh, are the container deep binary on-site?
I never really seen anything that I wanted
to see there.
Oh, okay. I got yeah. I don't know
why that's great. Like, I'll do a control
c and, like, kill the process.
There we go. Just stop it and, like
yeah.
P kill.
Point probably. I should probably do my s
nine.
And let's look at the container deep binaries.
User bin container.
Container d only. That is
Yeah. It's the same binary. Yep.
Okay. Container to the binary hasn't been touched,
but it's not working.
And there is a container to shim. Right?
Well, yeah, there's a whole bunch.
Why is the container edition run c v
one has, like, a different time stamp?
Yeah. But that's the same on the other
machine, so I'm okay with it.
Okay. Okay.
Although,
can it be can it oh, no. Because
we do it. Okay. That's why there's a
different amount of them. Yeah. Those look fine.
So that okay. The other machine also has,
the right one. Right?
Okay.
Well, it suggested we run the state is
to see if it left the config file.
It's in a mod probe over there. Supposed
to use a c group driver instead of
a six fifty driver?
Well, they're trying to stay this on a
control plane now to see if that Yep.
If anything's different. No. This is a working
node. Right? Okay. I have, like, so many
terminals open. I don't know which one.
Okay. Got it.
B p.
Okay. Am I in two worker nodes?
Yeah.
So I'm on the same machine trying to
compare the binaries,
I'm such an idiot.
Too many times.
See, that's different. So if we look at
the control plane, it's actually using the continuity
shim run c driver. But on the other
one, it's actually trying to use the system
to see through driver. So it must be
somewhere in the continuity config.
Yeah. Good catch. Okay.
So let's look at the also, let's look
at the binaries
on the control plane
since we are here.
So there is something called continuity.
So something was modified.
And if we do
So I bet the sham has been swapped
out.
That's what it is. Yep.
Yep.
Oh, not here.
Flash user opinion.
Alright. We wanna go Yep. I think the
shim was probably chopped, sapped out. Probably just
reinstalled container d.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's like
Hertz. Right?
Oh, I mean, just uninstall it.
Now let's do the app reinstall. It should
really fix it. I forgot how your computer.
There we go.
Okay.
But we should also check the system, the
config file because it was it must be
there and specify which c group I want
to use.
Well, I don't think there is a config,
which means it's just using the shims that
exist.
Ah, okay. Yeah. Let's try to start again.
Yeah.
Let's do a status and see if it
looks a bit healthier.
No? Okay. No. It's using something different.
So it must be let container d service.
Yep.
It
was I don't think this file should have
been
when we reinstall, this should be the right
one, but let's confirm. If it exists, I
think it would keep it the same.
No. Let's look at the right font from
the control pane also. System.
Let's see. Let's get
continuity.
So there must be config file that says
this used the wrong one.
Is there any, like
There must be something hidden. Right?
Yep. There's a specific configuration
files. We could say, like, which driver to
use.
You could, like, change it, but, like, it
must be in this continuity config. I don't
know which
yep. Let's see if it actually can list
the config. Yep.
Dumb.
Yeah.
And it it says
the shim is container d shim.
False. And let's try that container d
config
dump.
Get driver.
Well, need to just check-in our system d
system.
We don't have
a system d c group equal to false.
And what is the other one?
System d c group false.
Yep. It's saying
why is it using the wrong one?
Oh, there it okay. This is a
Alright. What does the control plane have for
plug in or disabled plug in, required plug
in?
Is there anything in there? Okay. Let's
minus
c five plug in. So You
can just less it. I'm just I'm gonna
go through it from the top. So why
don't we try that today? Sure.
So I've got version two.
Version two. Root. Yep.
On you go. I'll let you know that
if it's different.
Okay. So there's a root. There's a state
run container d, plug in directly, disabled, home
score, required plug in. GRPC,
that seems
yeah. I'm done.
Yep. C group part, t t r c.
What's the time out section? So I'm up
to the time out sections.
Debug is fine. Time out.
Okay. Plug ins.
Should do the report.
Oh, so this is where the cut image
was specified, the sandbox image.
Yeah. We've got 3.1 over here. It's, like,
too much con
should we copy it over and do a
dev?
Yeah. Let me copy the worker then.
Okay.
It's much easier than, like yeah. Them
worker conf.
Wait. We this is the same working on
itself. So there's no point in fixing it
here. We should copy it from the control
plane.
Oh, this is the plane. Sorry. Okay. Sorry.
We're
comparing this to
a container. Oh, yeah.
Dumb. Can I just, like, dumb, save the
file?
See, the death worker.
There's Ow.
So why is the worker not using the
system the
oh, hold on. I think it's well, this
could done by an environment variable.
That would be sneaky.
That is right.
So
okay. This is on the control plane. I'm
looking at that. Container
d.
No. I'll just be crap.
I guess I can't
understand. Right?
So we need this telling us to remember
the issue is CNI related. I think we
both believe that container d is unable to
start the CNI because of the system d's
scheduler. Yep. It's using some wrong,
like, shim.
Let's see system d.
Find
dot dash
type
f crap.
Oh, that's gonna continue the configuration here.
Alright. Let's try and use the container detail.
Like, it's gotta be able to not the
Yep.
What was that, though? Yeah. Like, there has
to be something.
I just find it so strange.
Oh, so it sees c group as system.
Okay. Yeah. It's using the c group. And
if I check it on the control
plane,
It's using the systemslicecontainer.t
search service and but, yeah, it's still been
then it's starting the container d process, which
starts with the container d share run c
v one. And here,
it's using running it inside
I
assume Qubelet has nothing to do with this.
Right?
Well, yeah, container d
would be running independently on the host and
speaking over gRPC.
So No. I want to, like because that
namespace. Right? Like, if you look at the
status, it says, like, the namespace case dot
I o. So
this is
must be something very silly configuration which we
have
Okay. Let's think about where can we where
can we provide
system deal overrides?
Did we really reinstall on this machine or
the
Yeah.
On this machine.
Correct dash r
dash I r.
Okay.
So how
about our
lab Lab.
System.
Okay.
Let's take a look. Oh, let's just go
into the target.
Multi
user.
I wonder if this dash
minus is that disabling the overlay? We don't
want that. Right?
I think
dash is something.
It's just loading the overlay plugin. Okay. But,
like, it says my okay. Let's try that,
though.
But I guess that's fine. I think, like,
I have seen dash. Yeah. It's a dash
thing. It's, normal in system deconfig. I don't
know what it really does, but
that read the man p. Yeah.
Okay.
Status.
Alright. That's, like, file that while it's set,
like there's, like, h c system, the system
dot conf dot d.
Okay. Where do you wanna go?
Etsy system d
and system dot conf. Oh, this does system
dot conf. Right? We don't have it.
Let's try an Etsy default.
That's where, like
like, sneaky things sometimes go.
Let's see. Default. Okay. Oh, we do have
a default. Grab. It's nothing in there.
Me see how it is getting started.
Let's system d y.
What if this is what if it's a
separate service? Right? What's the Oh, wait. Wait.
Wait. I guess I
so if I get the file oh, no.
It's in the same thing. Right? So I
was wondering, like, if it goes into Labs
system d, it might just use it for
system d thing. Okay. So control plane.
Something's weird. Right? We've restarted container d a
whole bunch of times. This system d collect
stuff has been running since April 6. I
think it's running independently
and it's just
maybe I think we can just shut that
down.
If we if we think it's causing a
problem, think we could just shut it down.
Yep. Probably.
Why is system d collector d then? Yeah.
I I'm killing it. Right? So
Alright.
D kill
system d
collect
or
Collector d. Yep. D.
No. That's it. Okay.
I think it's just come straight back.
Yeah. Okay.
The system has a command that tells you
which
unit file started the process. Right? But I
can't remember what it is.
If you do a cat or status, it
shows, like, the file. Right?
Let's do a tree. Like, if I get
it
There's
maybe maybe
it's not tree. Let's just do a status
completely.
Right. It's
saying it's registered under that slice.
Oh, so if I check the same thing
on
it was just system CPU status. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. Please
don't tell me it's the same.
No. It's different. Okay. Looks same.
The one there is degraded
on the control side. It's degraded.
Oh, look. There's a system decollector
on all the services.
Why is this?
Why is I don't know what this is?
So the control plane doesn't have anything related
to
system d collector.
There must be some config file we are
missing.
Just because Ah, let's see. C dash. I'm
gonna check the other cluster. I need
to know if this process is a red
heading and we're chasing something that just is
completely irrelevant. Oh, yeah.
I hope I don't see it here.
So this is the control plane.
Yep. It's
no. It's not using collected data. It's just
the Yeah. Control plane. This is the So
the g grid is, like, fine.
Yeah.
We need to get rid of that collector
plane. Wherever that is, that needs to go.
That's kinda where my head's at right now.
Do you agree? And
can you log in to a control plane
also from the other cluster just to make
sure if you're using the same thing?
Okay. It's the control plane, like like a
working node. Oh, the working node. Yeah. Of
course.
Yeah. Okay.
So we need to get rid of this.
This system deep thing is
is doing something bad to our container d,
and we need to
we need to get rid of it.
Let me try to find something like
Oh,
there's a container editor cons in the Etsy
modules lot on p. Let's check that. Yeah.
Just this. Already
I'll
just confirm
it's the same thing. I guess it's the
same. It should be up. All the Lithia
NetFilter. Those are, it just needed all those
modules. That's fine.
Trap
hunting.
Okay. There's there's, like, one file. So
we could do
did we have a prep for a system
decontroller?
I wonder if this is the system deconfig.
Like, if we go to I
wonder if it's some sort of process that's
supposed to do nice things and it's currently
being abused
here.
No. Yep.
Boy, I I think it's hard to use
LSO, or we could even, like, run continuity
with trace and see which conflict file is
loading.
But it's it's let's see. Let me
if we run the status, right, and and
filter for collector,
it runs on every unit. Like
Every unit has this thing now
or almost.
The continuity ones. Right?
Teleport and continuity. Teleport.
Why?
Oh, that is interesting. So it must be,
like, a CPL or something.
Should we just Google out for whatever that
system d control d is?
Just Google about it. Yeah. I did a
quick Google. I didn't find
anything that had me worried.
I got just the stable.
The stable.
Oh,
s as in Munich
dinner?
It's I just want to see which one
is in it. Presses, which says started as
been in it export.
I wonder if system d
running in a container.
No. It must not be.
That would be an impressive trick.
Yep.
I feel like
I don't know.
I am so confused.
It's strange that teleport is also doing the
same.
Does teleport use container d under the hood?
No. Teleport is installed on the nodes because
I don't trust people not to break it
if I run it in a container.
Okay. Those are
I will bind these. I was just looking
if there was like sampling or something.
And it's definitely using user Ben. Right?
Let's check. Yep.
Yep. User Ben continuity. User Ben continuity shim.
System
Yeah. You could go ahead and it seems
like the most innocent process in the world.
But yeah, I feel like it's the cause
of all our problems right now.
And I can't work out how system d
is
like, it's running as a sub process of
container d and teleport, but at the same
time,
hence the Should we just stop the like,
if there's, like, a a system d collector
d, system c t l,
data,
system d collectivity.
Right?
No. There is nothing.
Yeah.
Last year on entry.
Crap.
Yes. It's fine.
I'm tempted to remove the binary and restart
container d. Is that too aggressive?
Fine. We could, like, stop container d, like,
reinstall it again just to make sure.
Like, if we just say user lab system
d, system d.
In fact what's the timestamp on that fail
as well?
That's
innocent enough. But if we what else is
in that directory?
I don't trust anything.
The it's
it's it's tricky.
The timestamp is
strangely unique there.
Oh, okay. The binary.
And on the control plane?
Yeah. Let's check the worker the control plane.
You're right. Yeah.
It's under
user lib system b.
Oh, there's nothing called
He just left everything in that directory.
Yep.
Yeah. Our time data has been moved has
got a different timestamp too,
and there's no collector. Collectivity?
Is it, like, we could just delete the
collectivity binary and could just pick up the
shim?
Yeah. I think we can delete that file,
and
I'm gonna Move it to a yeah.
Let's
just move it to, like, a old dot
old or something and, like, yeah. I'm gonna
try something. Hold on. System d.
What was it? User lib.
The y libs. Okay.
Okay. Post slash system d.
Yep.
What are you?
GRPCR
address back to so it's something related to
container d.
Yeah.
Let's let's go in time just now. Right?
And then I'm not happy with the system
the timestamp.
Timed dated. What are you?
Yeah. You're look nefarious.
Let's get you that way.
System daemon. I don't think we need a
daemon reload, but
restart Yeah. Container daemon. Container
Kiblet.
Yeah. That's, like, the status of container d.
I checked the status of every oh, why
is that oh, we have to call that
process.
What?
Can we just remove it?
Yes.
Let's do that. Yes. You do. Yeah. Let's
check there.
Grab collected the
print
to
Sorry. Go
away.
Yeah. Go away.
Oh.
It did.
I have no idea what that fail was,
but it scares me now.
Let's run get pods.
Yep.
Look at that. It's working. Ah.
So, like, you just needed, like, kill all
those. Correct. Remove the binaries and do it
on other nodes. Yeah. I think we need
to go into the other do you wanna
grab x c, and I'll grab k d?
Sure.
That's user lib system d.
Move system d
collector to temp.
Move system d time dated to temp and
then restart of computer d.
Time to.
Yep. It's using the shim now.
So it's
it's getting past the NA container. Should we,
like, do the files and reinstall? Because the
Shim
time stamp was kind of, like, different. Right?
Got it.
Should we just, like, do a reinstall on
other nodes also, the container to reinstall?
I let's check the nodes. Let me check
the nodes and see if it actually.
Well, we're getting
we're still not getting our silly in pods.
Yep. I'll just, like, reinstall it. Yeah. Don't
have the note. Yeah. I'll do it on
the
k d.
It's
weird. It's like I I I don't know
if we've messed the system deconfiguration
option or if the system deconfiguration deconfigs up
the fact that that binary is there and
runs it somehow.
It could be that container depicts it up
because if we'll when it did a help,
right, it said one of the arguments that,
like, something related to container d. So it
must be something like, if it's present, I
think it'd be, like, just pick it up.
Come on, five.
Container d is Let me see. Not removing.
Oh, maybe I need I guess I should
have stopped it first.
Yep. We should have killed it. Yeah. I'm
gonna do that there.
Update another terminal now.
Mine doesn't stop. I see, like, a lot
of sleep.
So on the other node, I actually see
a lot of sleep in the when I
do a system CTL status
in the container d thing.
Yeah. A lot of sleep sixties. Oh, I
killed it. Yep. Part of sleep sixties.
Okay. Entering.
Good. There we go.
I'm gonna make sure that's definitely gone.
Oh,
okay. It's back up. Let me check the
note pods.
Yeah. My container do seems healthy.
Why does it say, like,
inspector?
Wow. I know it's needed.
So what
yeah. We deleted the Varlib container d, didn't
we, as well? Maybe we need to do
that on the other machine.
Yep.
Oops. I should have
Mhmm.
X c.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm just gonna stop Qublet also just in
case
and just start it again.
R f y. Think think the star. Star.
Tim can only explain what the system be
connected here. Like, Google itself doesn't know what
it is.
Okay. So it's continuity is exiting because
Yeah. If we do that, if we get
the logs again, you'll see there's a exit.
Compare the new template.
I run Cilium.
At the binaries also of c n I.
Exiting because of a signal.
Oh, but if you look at the c
the c l m c n night timestamp
is also kind of
and then heading in this node that I
am in, like, x c node.
It was just modified today.
Not Oh, no. We we did that. Right?
We we renamed maybe broken and replaced the
other one back.
Yep. And the control play was fine. I
meant the working node, the one that has,
like, x c,
the one I'm in.
Oh, yeah.
What was the directory called?
Op c n I bin.
Oh, yeah. That's because it's downloaded it when
the first image when the image finally started.
Alright. Okay. Yep. Let's find that. Yeah. I
think that's okay.
I think there's there must be something running
on these devices sending a signal.
To Civium.
Let's check all the processes.
Wonder what this is.
Why? Let's see. Java script. Why
is it Java?
Hubbell?
Potentially.
Let's grab that process ID.
P d prop.
Not there.
Well, it's gone now.
Is it like a cron?
That
would be sneaky, wouldn't it?
Yep.
I could like do a cron tab dash
l. I I do normally tell the breakers
I won't look in cron,
but I think given how much time was
spent on this, like, screw it. I'm gonna
cron tab dash. Oh.
That's bad. That's bad.
Alright. Let's check the other notes. Yep.
Okay. I'll fix it on mine, The one
that's in x c.
Wow.
Every minute.
Did we get them all?
Yep.
Let me check. I think so. Okay.
I guess so. I
thankfully, this was not on the control plane.
So that explains the signal and why C
and I was shut down. Yep.
And why is it, like, taking too long
to respond?
Oh, we probably just opened up a new
can of worms, haven't we?
Oh, let's check. Okay. I would probably, like
let's check any cron type exist here also.
Maybe, like, slowing it down or something.
And while he was talking about the s
two container d thing, but that was never
there.
Right? So it's yeah. We've just broken the
control. Should
we check the manifest
to see if it bothers, like let's do
the log verbose logs.
Yeah. Go for it. Please feel free.
Dash v.
Ah, so it if you went ahead and,
like so it's hitting the server. It's not
like any SSL thing this time. Actually, that's,
like, two servers. Probably, this is enough.
Two doesn't really go with anything.
No.
I don't want to, like, go over, like
but
it went up to the API server. Right?
Like, it says, like, we can see the
request went up to, like, eleven five hundred.
That's fine, I guess.
Okay.
Let's look at the server logs. Yeah. Yep.
Oh, we forgot to check the contact. Right?
I did. It's all good.
Yes. Nano, not them. So but there was
nothing in there. Oh,
okay.
Yeah. Let's check the APIs over the last
container
l s s r
less
cube.
Context It's CDP timeout.
That is not a meta dot v one
status. Just gonna scroll up a little.
I guess even if we had fixed the
limits issue yesterday,
we would have been still going down a
big habitat.
This is
one tricky damn cluster.
Is that today or yesterday? That's today. Right?
Yeah.
Looking at creating man what is this? Mandatory
flow control.
I just saw something.
What is it? Yep.
Do you think we should go take a
look at the
manifest again?
Yep.
Testing keys. It's not restarting, though, is it?
Like
Yeah. Let's not restart.
Oh, it's still running.
Oh, so there must be one of the
issues to API server.
Let's search for limits first.
Oh, sorry.
Now this I actually removed all the limits,
but I guess it's fine.
Oh, no. It was there. Okay. Oh, it's
running now. I just typed it wrong. Okay.
So
Should we try get again? Just to
Try a different namespace just
for no real rhyme or reason other than
I'm running out of ideas again.
Yeah. Let's just check the default, which has,
like, the least.
Okay. Let's do dash dash v. Oh, dash
v equal to nine. And we're less on
it.
Oh, so it's kinda stuck here. So it's
APS server taking time to respond. I
Is RTD running?
Oops. I give me minute. I accidentally closed
it.
Are
you happy?
Yeah. You're happy.
Should we check the No. It's not. That's
only been running for two seconds.
What?
Date. Date. Yeah.
Okay. It's been up for, like
Yeah. The time on the server is wrong.
What?
One 01:24PM.
Oh, no. No. Okay. Yeah.
That's
Yeah. That's right.
So SCD is only running a few minutes.
So probably it's like AP service that kind
of timing out, which is like since SCD
is not really up. Wow. It got restarted
again. Right? Yep. We need the SCD logs.
Yep.
What log?
Like,
what wrong folder. Yeah. Thank
you.
Bar log. There we go. Yeah.
Let's find the last one.
Alright.
I think
I find yours.
That looks okay. Oh, we should take the
limit for that CD.
Probably the limits for it CD is also
set to or that it probably, like, takes
a long while too.
And since we are now hitting it with
the more load
yep.
Done. This better be the last fix. Come
on.
Okay. So it's restarting just now because we
don't have entity.
I'm gonna do a quick search for the
limits in this directory.
Alright. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Good. Good.
It's taking its time. Taking a long
is there, like, limits set for
Kubelet too, like, from system t?
I'm gonna restart the Kubelet.
Yeah?
No? Sure.
Am I just being Let's wait for one
more minute, Cap.
I'm just being impatient, Arna. That's a long
time.
Should we just, like, kill it so that
it starts it?
There we go. Okay. Yep. It's fine.
K. I think you will have to get
healthy. So
Yep.
We can always Well, let's check AP server.
Health.
Health. Okay.
No.
I feel like we're close.
Let's get it. That's
errors. Top and tech
okay. Yeah. That's errors. Okay.
Yeah.
Pod security policy. No.
How could it, like, break one sister fixed
Centimeters?
Object to
That
doesn't appear to be too healthy.
Oh. Oh, it's back.
Oh.
I hate that show.
Okay. Set is not up. Let's start very
important. Yeah. Are we using any more volume
for that?
Yeah. Funny, Valid. Sorry.
I know what what you're saying there.
So Seth is not running, but I was
asking, like, are there any ports that use,
like, a PVC? Yeah. The postgres one.
Ah, okay. I think it might just take
a bit. Let's check if the serial ports
are all up.
I I think we should just
oh. Oh.
So we have two running. So there's only
one that's in crack now. They're like so
how many nodes do we have for?
The worker node and one control plane and
and three workers. Three. Right? We fixed the
limb. Right? That was the cron job kill.
Unable to reach API server. Okay. So we
did restart some stuff. So I'm going to
restart Cilium.
That's better.
Right?
Yep.
Sometimes, see the eventual consistency.
Sometimes, like, at times, it takes, like, forever
to, like, reconcile.
That's good. There we go. Things are happy.
Yep.
Oh, great. And Don't worry, Miles. We are
all over it. We are restarting everything within
our power.
Rawkode gets
is it DS?
Oh, no. It's Rawkode. Yeah.
Get deploy.
There's only You should copy. Those coming back,
right,
I think? Yep. I guess it's yeah. Let's
take the pods.
Maybe you should just, like
yeah. Don't know. Do the pod.
Okay.
I I don't wanna suspend too much longer
on this. I think we've it's been good
fun, but
Yep.
We've
fixed a lot. And I'm hoping if we
just keep an eye on this Rawkode namespace
for a moment, we'll start to see that
come out here.
There was a lot in this story. Yeah.
It's our name.
So what Rawkode has so many components.
Yeah. It's also because of the machine I'm
I'm installing these on. So, like, these are
quite beefy machines, and it creates an OSD
for every disk that is available to be
consumed by the CSI driver.
And, you know, it
Rec and are really cool, but the more
No. I I think
CSI is, like, kind of pretty heavy if
you look at the number of ports it
creates.
Almost I think I run long haul. It
also has, a ton of ports running almost
all the time.
Okay. I guess it's all backup.
Yeah. This is getting healthy. Let's check our
actual application,
and I'm gonna go to my local terminal.
But let's see if we can port forward.
Yeah. Rawkode. Yep.
Rawkode.
Clustard.
16.
Export config.
K. Get pods.
Or forward.
Alright. Let's see.
Okay. So we're not probably
Rawkode
thing. Right? We should probably just delete the
post present.
Ah, he's changed the service.
Just one last kick in the shins before
you
alright. Let's see.
Target port.
Thank you. We can just remove target port.
It's not a big deal.
Alright. Port forward. Yep.
DNS.
Oh, let's check if code here is actually
up.
Should we just restart the post? Because since
we had, like, a three restarts,
like,
the vault.
Oh, the back end load controller is actually.
That's okay. I I don't care about the
the
packet the packet one I think is is
alright. I think I I think I like
your idea about restarting
Postgres.
I thought the surface So
when you
Sorry. Go. Oh, so when I list the
pods from the machine, the control play, I
only see, like, two pods, but, like, use
it three.
Oh, that's weird.
Yep. So if I do just get pod,
I just see class like, two pods and,
like, use it three. I don't know why.
Is it, a right cluster?
Oh, no. It's a fifteenth cluster. It's 16.
Wow.
Alright. Okay.
K. K.
Port
or well, at least we found another bug
injected by Matt Anderson then. Thanks, Matt. Yep.
That cluster was fun too. Right.
Ta da. Yeah.
This is just a Firefox bug. It doesn't
like the encoding on my video. That's the
only reason it doesn't No. It's fine. Yeah.
But we have fixed I guess. We have
fixed this cluster.
Yep.
Very close.
Yeah. I don't think this video works on
Firefox. I need to re encode it with
something else.
Few. There we go. Well done.
Yep.
Alright. Well,
I know we we put a lot of
time into these two clusters last night and
today. So thank you for joining me again.
No.
Yep.
That was a really really tricky one, but
we got there in the end.
Perseverance definitely prefer. So thank you again for
joining me. Have a great day and I
will speak to you again soon. Yep. Bye.